we turn now to the covid pandemic and
the huge impact on health care workers
nearly 3 600 of them have died of covid
in the u.s one study found that 41
percent of health care workers are
considering leaving the profession for
good chris van cleef traveled to
kentucky to see the struggle that our
health care workers face every single
day
across rural kentucky life largely has
gone back to normal but the battle
against the pandemic still rages inside
health care facilities even in tiny
owingsville about 50 miles east of
lexington the only thing that is
semi-comparable and not even close is
like a battlefield and we've been
fighting now for two years dr aaron
parker banks is the only doctor on that
coveted battlefield at this family
clinic he sees about 40 patients a day a
third due to covet what do you think
about at night when you're finally able
to stop working whenever i'm at home i
try not to talk about what all is going
on at any moment if i start thinking
about it i cry
there's 35 individuals in bath county
who are no longer here some of those 35
people were folks that were close to you
i understand
yeah
i've had friends i've had family members
one of my mentors growing up who was
like a mom to me she lost her battle 20
miles east in moorhead the patients in
this coveted surge unit are
sick and in some cases could be in an
icu except the icu is full of even
sicker patients
it's been all hands on deck for two
years the toll on health care workers
means there are now fewer hands to help
lift the load how hard is it to replace
the nurses that have left
well you can't replace experience so you
have to rebuild
every nurse is
a critical frontline provider
first courtney hollingsworth says
balancing burnout is now just part of
the job we have to
just keep waking up each day and
remembering
why we do
what we do
to make a difference a difference she's
determined to keep making with so many
people leaving healthcare does it
make you worry about the future oh i'm
scared to death of the future you know
before covet started we needed more
people to go into health care there
wasn't enough but it is
it is so scary what's scary about it
that there won't be enough
of us to be able to take care of the
needs of the patients
there are still a lot of needs across
the commonwealth of kentucky 87 percent
of icu beds are full at this hospital
about a quarter of the patients are
coveted positive a survey of kentucky
nurses taken last fall found roughly one
in four said they were thinking about
leaving their job within three months
nate
chris thank you so much
you know we recognize that with staffing
issues the hours they work there's a
physical toll right but i don't think we
oftentimes talk about the mental toll
of our healthcare workers you know like
we heard he goes home and he says i
don't even want to think about it
because i'll start crying start crying
and you know we these stories are really
important because i know people are
tired people want this pandemic to be
over but clearly it is not done with us
and when you hear that we may not have
enough health care professionals to
treat sick people
in the days and weeks ahead yeah that's
why it's important this is the other
side of the protection issue because if
your health care system collapses many
say
the nation isn't far behind yeah and try
not to think about it selfishly oh what
was me if we don't have enough health
care workers how about we we take that
extra step forward and show our
appreciation it's just like if you have
a heart attack or if you get sick and
you go to the hospital they don't have
doctors there to treat exactly exactly
they either left or sadly they've died
overworked underpaid and
underappreciated so we should do our
part to show them the love that they
deserve